your favorite question is would you you
ask all friends if they would show up to
your funeral if they had a big gig that
weekend all right oh no no you don't
have to add that
yeah how about would i just go if it was
in the valley
so if i if i die
dave if i died
and um
it was on a saturday
and
saturday was day one
day one
on wrong missy part two
in hawaii would you call
production and go i gotta show up the
next day
because i have to go to bobby lee's
funeral
i would
see if anyone was zooming it while
i think there was
during wrong missy
oh brody happened oh that's right were
you there
was it i never went yeah i think i was
in hawaii maybe no you weren't it was
right before hawaii you guys were
probably in hawaii already that was my
excuse what was mike's no you weren't it
happened the week before you had to go
to hawaii to shoot your stuff well why
didn't i go to a week but did i go to a
funeral oh no you were in the
philippines i was in the philippines yes
thank god i was in the [ __ ]
philippines that's why i didn't go i was
about to say
yeah yeah that would have been a tough
one though
yeah i like brody a lot i we had been
done the road for that year before a
year and a half i got to know him the
best that just at that last year and a
half so would have been tough
it was um
you know there was there's been a couple
of comedy deaths yeah you know it's and
his
was so sudden right yeah just out of the
[ __ ] blue
and you know i've said this before but
you know when she told me that brodia
died i was sleeping
you know when you're sleeping did you
forget or something no she woke me she
goes it was 4 pm but 4 p.m and she goes
it's 4 p.m
that changes a little bit yeah
yeah 4pm and she goes um
sweetie um oh no
horrible brody died
and i go what
brody stevens died
and i laid there for maybe a minute
still sleeping
and then i go
why am i not crying
and then she goes this is what she says
because you're still sleeping like
mid-sleep you know again when you wake
up
you will of course and as soon as i woke
up yeah it was uh and then you can be
pretty sensitive you canceled your
weekend in irvine yeah cancel my weekend
irvine um david's got to go but so what
we got to do is before you go we do a
game is that a game okay no it's called
unhelpful advice and people email us
problems oh good and we answer them you
know what's funny is that
you're right
what do you mean
i don't like you anymore
it's gonna take two minutes this is way
too late
here's a quick question unhelpful advice
with bobby kalila and david spade
hi guys i'm an 18 year old in a group of
alpha personalities we all try to
dominate to be the most dominant guy in
our group if you were in this situation
how did you handle it or if not how do
you handle it without being an [ __ ]
about it thanks for your help noah
how old is he 18.